no series about who rules america can
leave out wall street's financial clout
we've left its impact for last secure in
the knowledge that in today's america
this financial district is a key power
center a hub for the financialization of
an economy in which the control of big
money is often central to the control of
politics and society
we have spoken with a respected
corporate executive who told us point
blank that the rich now rule america
my personal opinion is
a large part of what's happening
economically
is due to basically globalization and
digitization of business that can't be
stopped
professor stanley iranowitz quotes the
famous sociologist c wright mills on the
same theme from 50 years ago
wall street the financial sector
is the leading edge of corporate capital
and it was a leading edge of corporate
capital in the mid 50s of course today
it's much more accentuated because of
the relative decline of industrial uh uh
corporations
i've heard things that'll blow your mind
and now i think it's time you get the
whole story
many americans see all this as a
conspiracy by an unaccountable secret
cabal that operates like a power center
beyond democratic control the internet
is filled with videos about shadowy
billionaires in their plots that control
everything which is ongoing right now
it is a conspiracy of institutional
corruption from the highest level
from international bankers to the super
rich
from washington to rome
they're all in it together
is wall street a conspiracy and what
role does it play in who rules america
is it an outside job or an inside job
it's not a matter of
elites outside the state although of
course they have enormous influence but
the reason they have enormous influence
because because the state is structured
to be reproducing their power and
authority
in society leo panitch
he's a
economist and analyst
and i think he offered a perspective
that we really haven't heard before he's
sort of fighting against a
conspiratorial idea you know that
there's a small group of people in a
room somewhere running things he's
talking about the structure of the
society the values of it who really runs
things
wall street is not only a place it's an
industry with thousands of
interconnected firms that call
themselves a financial services industry
but they are much more than that they
are deeply involved with how our country
is run says robert weissman the head of
the public interest group public citizen
well you can't understand what's
happened in the country in the last 30
years
in terms of economic policy really the
way the country's evolved politically
without understanding how wall street
has grown in power it's grown in
economic power and it's grown in
political power and that's been
synergistic they use their political
power to wipe out a whole range of
regulations that control them
in the past investors would buy stocks
in real companies and industries that
generated jobs provided services or
created products of value those days are
gone
it became a bigger and bigger portion of
the economy
then we went from an economy of
production making things to one based on
consumption buying and selling things
consumers soon drove 70 percent of the
economy as banks private equity
companies and hedge funds grew in size
as it became a bigger portion of the
economy they were able to leverage more
and more political power and a really
horrible cycle for the functioning of
democracy and what that led us up to of
course was the crash in 2008. so
consumers went deeper and deeper into
debt and then bankers bought and sold
debt while they changed the rules
regulating their activities a whole
series of deregulatory moves that had
been enabled by the
influence the political influence of
wall street led to
the actual functioning economy to be a
disaster
because as billionaire investor george
soros told me years ago the capitalist
economy is also inherently unstable and
prone to bubbles and crashes
i i work with the
theory that
financial markets
are inherently unstable
and
to
prevent
excesses you need some kind of
intervention supervision regulation
uh unfortunately
the prevailing
idea is that markets stand towards
equilibrium
and so we work with a false
concept
of how financial markets operate
we were told by someone for example that
the beauty of globalization is that no
one is in control
well it there is a great advantage in
that uh because
controls have their own problems uh
in fact markets are much more efficient
than centralized controls but it doesn't
mean that that there should be
absolutely no
control and in fact if you look at
reality
ever since you've had capitalism and
ever since you have had financial
markets you have had a
crises and each time there was a crisis
there was something done
to prevent a recurrence
the problem this time is the dramatic
surge in debt look at this these are
charts showing the debt of the united
states page after page illustrating how
much money is owed it's mind-boggling
it gets even more complicated when you
start talking about new financial
instruments like derivatives that have
turned the industry into a global casino
derivatives can also be used as
insurance betting that alone will or
won't default before a given date they
become the basis of a big betting system
like in a casino
financial journalist max keiser says
just a handful of big financial firms
now dominate the industry and the global
economy
without a doubt there's jp morgan which
is in bed with the fed into the central
banking system
wall street bets on future values and
the performance of practically
everything of value
so you've got morgan goldman sachs are
the two primary uh players in this in
this global financialized world
soon ceos financiers and executives of a
small number of investment banks and
hedge funds became rich and powerful by
controlling specialized high-stakes
markets
they are connected to the central
banking system which is the fed the ecb
the bank of international settlements in
switzerland is kind of the central bank
of the central banks uh and the these
are the folks that are keeping their
main purpose at this point is to keep
interest rates as close to zero as
possible to make it as cheap as possible
for people who are borrowing money to
speculate to be able to speculate freely
without having to pay for the money that
they're borrowing to speculate
even if these financial markets are
supposedly open to all a relatively few
traders investors and asset managers
came to structure the markets to
increase their own wealth and power
if they ever make a bad bet then they
quickly move to cover their bad bets
with austerity programs or some kind of
bailout program or a quantitative easing
program
a swiss study by physicists on the
ownership and control of stock exchanges
in 48 countries examined twenty four
thousand eight hundred and seventy seven
stocks and a hundred and six thousand
one hundred and forty one shareholding
entities to their amazement they found
that just ten companies were dominating
all stock ownership here they are
when we talk about money and we talk
about wall street we have to ask this
question where does the money come from
that's used in the speculation in our
financial markets this man knows barry
james dyke he's an asset manager and he
works with clients so where does it come
from
the money comes from people savings
regular savings were people's retirement
funds which is saving for retirement but
to the people who put their money into
these accounts know how it's being
invested or spent they don't have a clue
it's only now as a result of the
financial crisis that the public is
learning slowly that the self-styled
masters of the universe on wall street
speculated on risky investments and
created a crash
green carter the editor of vanity fair
wrote it can fairly be said that the
chain of catastrophic bets made over the
past decade by a few hundred bankers may
well turn out to be the greatest
non-violent crime against humanity in
history
they brought the world's economy to its
knees lost tens of millions of people
their jobs in their homes and crashed
the retirement plans of a generation and
they could drive an estimated 200
million people worldwide into dire
poverty
in 2010 before occupy wall street labor
unions were marching to protest wall
street crimes
[Music]
[Applause]
on the 29th of april this is a march on
wall street organized by the afl cio
which says they've organized 200
protests so far but you never know it in
terms of the media coverage well today
the media is out and they're marching
because of a theft millions of jobs are
missing 11 million jobs according to the
afl cio they want payback they want wall
street to pay they want a new tax on
financial transactions
[Music]
we are trying to recover from a
financial crisis that some people say is
even worse than the depression in the
1930s and yet reforms that have been
proposed very modest reforms are being
fought tooth and nail at the regulatory
level by wall street firms and
financiers uh do you think that they
have a disproportionate power to
influence congress there's no doubt
about that
not just the congress but state
legislatures as well
their strength their power
runs the entire gambit of the of the
american political system
i read that the financial services
industry had hired 28 lobbyists per
member of congress to try to influence
their decisions to try to inform how
what happens to you when lobbyists come
into your office to try to get you to
vote their way how does that work that
game well it's very hard to to get a
meeting with me i don't think that they
spent a lot of money trying to lobby me
i'm kind of clear on my ideology clear
my view of representative government and
very clear on on the constitution but
suffice it to say while my district is
competitive there are many more
competitive districts than mine
and every member of congress to that
extent becomes a prisoner
to the election process to the
fundraising process
sheila krumholz of the center for
responsive politics says wall street's
power is well documented
wall street the banks and the financial
industry writ large is the single
largest source of campaign cash
in the united states and it has been for
years if not decades
it is uh
kind of following the willie sutton rule
of politics you go where the money is
that's where the money is they have not
just political action committees that
can pony up
maximum amounts to influential members
of congress who have jurisdiction over
their industry but also they can pony up
pass the hat and pony up hundreds of
thousands of dollars just among their
partners and vice presidents and
executives and their companies she says
their clout will impact the election in
2012.
so they can muster a ton of money and
this is also
seen specifically in the presidential
race in 2012 where of course mitt romney
has hailed from uh the private ind
private equity industry and prior to
that barack obama had been darling of
wall street so
wall street and and banks in particular
uh are an enormously influential part of
the u.s
industry
that power is being shown as wall street
lobbyists try to sabotage financial
reforms passed by congress
two years after the passage of the
legislation and are the regulators doing
the good things that congress told them
to do and the answer to a considerable
extent is no they're way behind on
issuing the rules they're supposed to
issue where they actually have issued
the rules are getting challenged in
almost every instance in court by the
chamber of commerce or the financial
securities roundtable or other wall
street interests
and they're having a tough time with the
judiciary that's favorable to big
business and maintaining the rules that
they've issued so reforms can be passed
but they can also be sabotaged
right they get multiple bites at the
apple they get a bite in congress
where they've got enormous power but at
least it's mostly a public fight and
then they go to the regulatory agencies
where they also have enormous power but
it's usually below the radar off the
front pages and they don't even have the
public scrutiny
recently on a radio show i host i
discussed wall street power and the
financial meltdown with financial
journalists max kaiser and stacy herbert
as well as andy stepanyan an animal
rights activist who led a campaign
against the company in the business of
painful medical tests on puppies after
his group drove their stock price down
the company went broke but then the
government labeled him a financial
terrorist and sent him to prison
we began by comparing wall street to the
titanic the unsinkable ship that sank
if the titanic or the story today the
difference would be that goldman sachs
and jp morgan would have
heavy bets
that would pay off when the ship sinks
and hank paulson would be down there
widening the gash
it brings me to a new study out just
recently and they looked at hundreds of
shipwrecks throughout the hundreds past
few hundred years what they found is
that the norm is actually for women and
children to die more frequently than men
and that the captain usually didn't go
down with the ship they were usually the
their survival rate was the highest
these guys they
they use derivatives as warren buffett
calls them weapons of mass financial
destruction to
to make situations worse because their
bets that they have uh on on these
calamities becoming worse pay off
enormously and we see that in the in the
numbers in the bonuses it's reflected
and you were nodding before when max was
speaking about
all of this is this really true that
they're betting against
you know us in a sense betting against
uh you know hoping for bad things to
happen i don't think that everybody that
works on wall street has this mentality
but there is a culture that's in place
where people
have have learned to at least accept and
and justify behavior like looking
at these investments betting investments
against
you know things to fail whether it be a
government whether it be a country or
whether it be a company to fail and and
say oh well i can justify this and you
look at it like it's numbers you don't
look at the people behind it you don't
look at the families that suffer you
don't look at the country that suffers
as a result
well here's what what you know is
mind-boggling to me
is you are presenting a picture of
intentionality
that people did things to further their
own interests they knew what they were
doing
it was calculated and yet
in most of the media
it seems as if it's presented as some
sort of mistake as miscalculation uh g
we wanted housing to go up but it went
down you can't blame us everybody was
doing it there therefore nobody was
doing it therefore nobody can be
prosecuted let's assume that there was
intention is that a good thing or a bad
thing some would argue that it's it's a
good thing to have people who are who
are parasites in an economy because
parasites are useful i have parasites in
my intestines they perform a useful
function the problem is the parasites
don't run my heart lungs and brain
in in america the parasites write the
regulatory framework that's supposed to
be governing them so the parasites are
on their show is wall street affecting
you know capital is wall street
affecting our policy making well they're
becoming our policy makers at least for
a short period of time and then
returning back to the banks
and there's an evolving door kind of
thing essentially i mean they're in and
out of whether it be the bush
administration or the obama
administration the
different
positions within the cabinet that are
you know governing finance are
individuals that are
former ceos of banks or they might go
back to being an honorary chair on the
board of directors it's it's this
incestuous relationship between wall
street and policy sounds so corrupt
danny you asked who runs america and i
say it's ignorance and you know thomas
jefferson warned of this
and that we needed
a media who would inform the population
otherwise we would lose our democracy so
this is ignorance that is being forced
upon criminalizing knowledge this is
something that i was startled by when
nasdaq opened up you know on in times
square a big studio out front with a big
window and you know and then i said i'd
love to tour the exchange
and uh you know this was the time that
bernie madoff was running
nasdaq you know and they said you can't
tour the exchange there is no exchange
it looks like in exchange there's a
building that says
nasdaq but the actual operations are
computers algorithmic trading goes well
beyond that
as you're alluding to it's not about
individuals who are taking any risks
personally to make a market as part of a
capitalist system these are computers
that have virtually unlimited credit
because the cost of credit is now zero
and the ability for a bank like jpmorgan
with a 90 trillion dollar balance sheet
of derivatives they can lend a trillion
dollars to a computer program to make a
bet if the bet doesn't work then they
get a federal bailout if the bet works
then they get a bonus so it's heads they
win tails we lose and this has been
going on now for a number of years but
it's gotten shockingly more
disproportionate and asymmetric
this shift towards super fast computers
is just another example of the deeper
shift we've seen in power as finance in
effect takes over with politicians
courting wall street at global
conferences and in private meetings as
george soros explains
it is actually symptomatic
of the age because you have
presidents and prime ministers courting
the
the the financiers and the
industrialists
uh
so it does show a shift
in in in
the relative
power but i
i don't want to
convey
see i don't believe
that
that business can in any way replace
the power of the state because it's
different kind of power so the the
sovereignty is still in the hands of the
state
wall street you know it sounds like a
conspiracy theory but wall street
controls everything you know i mean
they're the major shareholders of all
the major companies look at the bp oil
spill who is the owner of bp oil spill
the biggest shareholder is jp morgan
there's so much happening now you know
there's no stopping what's happening now
the system everyone knows the system's
broken whether you're you know a one
percenter or 99 or republican a democrat
anarchist communist
capitalist everyone knows the system is
broken so now we need to fix it
we'll give the last word to a scholar
with a longer view american historian
eric foner
i think what we face is a serious
democracy deficit not only in the united
states but in many other countries as
well i'm not quite ready to say a
plutocracy determines everything that
happens in the united states but i think
the democracy deficit arises from the
fact that
fundamental issues are now just off
limits from democracy
it doesn't matter who is elected the
basic issues about finance about
de-industrialization
uh things like that are about
globalization about the loss of power of
ordinary people over their own lives
that's not open to discussion i don't
care if it's democrat republican obama
romney
that's not part of what their debate is
you their debate is at the margins so
that the fundamental issues facing
ordinary people are not subject to
democratic consideration government does
not represent the ordinary people
even though people elect the government
the government does not respond at all
to the needs and aspirations of ordinary
people
in this series we've investigated who
rules america examining the history of
deep conflicts in this country going
back to the american revolution we've
dissected the power of the military
corporations the media and wall street
we have shown that these powerful forces
often undermine democracy rather than
strengthen it
there is a battle underway for the soul
of america for who rules america that
has put these deeper issues on the
agenda the question is a fundamental
transformation possible or will special
interests and the wealthiest americans
continue to dominate in a country that
says it's the most dynamic democracy on
earth
the belief in our democracy is almost an
article of religious faith even though
there's a separation of church and state
perhaps that's why the views you've
heard in this series are rejected by the
establishment rejected by academia
rejected by the press they believe only
the people have power if anyone does
but opinion leaders don't look into it
they don't focus on interest they focus
on ideologies on personalities not
institutions the idea of a power elite
is an anathema
to them
because if people believed it that might
spur dissatisfaction and dissent
the age of the internet and global
television you can't stop people from
being exposed to counter narratives to
official myths these issues are
debatable of course but most political
coverage doesn't debate other ways of
looking at the world it relies on the
usual pundits recycling conventional
wisdom
they don't ask who rules america
members of congress i have the high
privilege and the distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of the
united states
thank you so much
[Applause]
you